put on your revenge dress and get ready
to suck on some toes sucking Sarah's
toes mummy
what cause the second last season of the
crown is out which focuses on one of the
most tumultuous times for the modern
royal family the breakup of Diana and
Charles in this video we'll be taking a
deep dive into season five the real
history and much much more so grab your
tickets to Apollo 13. Houston we have a
problem this is going to get messy the
final episode of the season is titled
decommissioned at reference to the Royal
yacht Britannia being put out of service
after 43 years in fact the very first
scene of the Season we see Claire Foy
who portrayed the queen in seasons one
and two christening this ship the ship
itself becomes a metaphor for the
Queen's Reign One which started off with
cheers and praise only to be left
falling apart and left in disrepair it
shouldn't come as a surprise she's
falling apart she's a creature of
another age in fact the very final shot
of the entire season is the queen alone
on the once Majestic ship before it's to
be dismantled one of the biggest themes
of this season is tradition versus
change with the queen Clinging On To The
Past while Charles seeks to save the
monarchy by embracing change in fact the
prince creates his own war council of
sorts to drum up ideas on how best to
adapt he'll even hold a secret meeting
with new Prime Minister Tony Blair
someone seen as a beacon of change for
the UK as Charles will later tell his
mother what good is holding on to the
past if there will be nothing for him to
take over the main events of season 5
take place between 1991 and 1997 with
the core story following the dissolution
of Diana in Charles's marriage from
episode 1 we're shown that this is far
from the fairy tale marriage projected
to the public Diana is stuck in a
Loveless marriage where her husband has
frequent affairs with Camilla Parker
Bowles as she'll later tell Martin
beshear in her interview well the three
of us marriage so it's a bit crowded and
while Diana wants to do exciting new
things with her kids like go shopping or
to the movies Charles clings to the Past
referring to Regale people about ancient
history it's kind of ironic since
Charles fancies himself as a beacon of
modernity at least in relation to his
mother feeling utterly helpless and the
queen too busy to give her the time of
day Diana uses her friend James colters
as an intermediary between her and
journalist Andrew Morton she wanted the
people to know her side of the story and
what better way than a book A book which
will come to be known as Diana her true
story much of the British population at
the time still believed in the Diana
Charles fairy tale so when news came out
of her multiple suicide attempts Charles
is cheating and her mistreatment it
created an absolute Firestorm the show
does a pretty good job depicting how
Morton and Diana went about making this
book in secret as Morton provided a
detailed account on how they
corresponded shortly after Diana's death
even the break-in of Morton's apartment
actually had happened of which only a
camera was taken and no one knows who
was responsible but the constant
sweeping of Diana's office for bugs did
indeed happen although nothing was ever
found this paranoia is what eventually
makes it so easy for BBC journalist
Martin beshear to manipulate her into
giving him an interview even though
other high-profile networks and names
like Oprah Winfrey and Barbara Walters
could have easily nabbed the job Martin
went so far as to create doctored Bank
documents to show a connection between
the British government and inner members
of Diana and her brother's security team
in November of 2020 that BBC held an
independent investigation into how
Martin secured the interview with the
May 2021 report finding him guilty of
using deceitful methods that breached
the BBC's editorial conduct that same
month he resigned from his position at
the BBC stating health reasons the
interview itself was secretly held at
Kensington Palace where Martin and his
crew gained access under the pretense of
installing a new audio system
coincidentally or not the inter view was
conducted on November 5th or guy Fox
night named after an Infamous member of
the Gunpowder Plot which sought to kill
King James in 1606. with the interview
complete editing was done under constant
surveillance by security at the Grand
Hotel in Eastbourne which was cheekily
named the Queen's hotel for the show as
expected the interview made headlines
around the world and a few months later
Charles and Diana's divorce would be
finalized in episode 9 there's an almost
12 minute long final scene between the
prince and Diana which acts as a
distillation of their entire marriage it
starts off flirty and fun gets serious
and by the end everything falls to
Pieces laying the groundwork for Diana's
eventual meeting with Dodi fayer you may
be surprised but there's only one scene
between Diana and Dodie the entire
season and in it they basically just say
hello and that's it more time however is
spent on Dodie's father Muhammad from
his humble upbringing in Egypt to
multi-millionaire obsessed with being
accepted by the British Elite but why
would the show Focus so much attention
on the father rather than on the man who
will eventually fall in love with Diana
that's because it's absolutely vital to
understand who Muhammad is to
contextualize Dodie Muhammad spent most
of his life revering the British trying
desperately to become one of them this
involved hiring King Edward's personal
Valley in order to teach him what it
took to become an English gentleman he'd
even go on to buy herod's department
store a quintessential English
institution throughout the season we see
how Dodie tries desperately to gain the
love and acceptance of his father he
wins an Oscar for financing a movie
about an outsider trying to become an
Insider this of course being 1981's
Chariots of Fire he brings over a white
supermodel Kelly Fisher hoping she'll be
pretty enough for his acceptance but
what Dodie fails to realize is that he's
not giving his father what he really
wants that acceptance into British high
society and what better way to get that
than by dating the most beloved Royal
Princess Diana and at the end of the
season they now single Princess Diana is
asked to accompany Mohammed at his wife
on his private yacht in San Tropez there
she can spend the summer with her boys
and do all the things Charles so hated
like speed boating and shopping
obviously this is all a setup for season
six Dodie allegedly left fiance Kelly
Fisher who then sued him claiming he
abandoned her for Diana this lawsuit was
dropped after Dodie and Diana's tragic
passing a memorial of Diana and Dodie
was erected at herod's where you could
see the lipstick smudged wine glass from
Diana's final dinner and a ring Fayed
purchased the day before they died the
final few episodes also gives us a small
glimpse into Diana's life away from the
royals she had a relationship with a
Pakistani cardiologist Dr haznet Khan
they dated for almost two years and she
visited Pakistan twice between 1996 and
1997 at the invitation of Imran Khan a
man who would later become Prime
Minister of Pakistan and who was also
related to haznat we see Diana voting no
to the monarchy on a broadcast called
monarchy the nation decides this was a
real TV program which asks some
hard-hitting questions surrounding the
current monarchy with 66 percent of
respondents in favor of the institution
but only 48 percent believing the
monarchy would survive another 50 years
at the Queen's birthday Charles's
heartfelt present of a drawing he did
for his mother is overshadowed by
Andrew's singing bass it is commonly
been cited that Andrew was the Queen's
favorite child but I'm not so sure about
that lately Charles once again believes
his talents are wasted as he's sent to
represent the Royals at Britain's
Handover of Hong Kong to China but at
least that affords him the opportunity
to get closer with new Prime Minister
Tony Blair who took a large majority in
Parliament as member of the new labor
party Charles believes that he and Blair
could make an invaluable team as both
want change he even goes against his
mother telling him that the Royal yacht
should be decommissioned as it's a relic
of the past meanwhile the queen has her
last official meeting with prime
minister John Major who served in that
role for over six years the show depicts
him as having helped to mediate the
settlement between Diana and Charles
however there's no evidence of that in
reality this agreement only took about
two months on his way to Hong Kong
Prince Charles is subjugated to business
class as the new prime minister and his
Pals enjoy champagne in first class he
had another depiction of the Royals
losing their status Princess Diana
attends a rendition of Swan Lake and apt
ballet since it's all about a prince
falling in love with a princess only for
her to become cursed after Muhammad
invites her out for dinner there's some
brief foreshadowing of her death being
chased by Paparazzi no doubt what season
six will focus on the death of British
rule over Hong Kong is also shown with
Charles stating that this is the result
of not adapting to the times the show as
well as PM Tony Blair depict Charles as
a sympathetic figure with Tony calling
him an impressive man and that his job
must feel like being trapped in
opposition for eternity back home the
queen chastises her son on taking the
Royal yacht not only to conduct a
personal meeting with the PM something
only this sovereign is to do but also to
engage in a holiday with Camilla he's
upset that she has failed to move with
the times and she like her yacht will
become decommissioned leaving him with
nothing she must cast aside these
Victorian Notions of how the monarchy
should be the season ends with Muhammad
arriving on his yacht and Dodie's
proposal to Kelly as Diana packs for the
trip no doubt this is all a setup for
what's to come we even get a slight
smile from Diana signaling that this
might be the start of something new a
way towards happiness but just as the
season started with a queen so does it
end she takes one last tour of the
Britannia ending with her reflection in
the mirror will she continue down the
same path as the monarchy crumbles
around her to suffer the same fate as
her ship or will she adapt and change
season 6 likely won't be around until
November of 2023 but casting has already
begun for older versions of William and
teenage Kate Milton so it looks like
season 6 will cover Diana's death and a
few years after with it being the final
season of the series thanks for watching
everyone be sure to like And subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on Twitter and Instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember sucking Sarah's
toes mummy